hey how you been
i'm doing good nice to see you yeah it's
been a while
a little bit um i want to start with
congratulations on booking 1883.
uh i have a feeling it's going to be
what we call a big hit
i hope so thank you i'm confident um one
of the things about watching the series
is it just reminds me how rough the old
west was and the westward expansion can
you sort of talk about how much did you
know about just how tough it was to do
that
this show has um
we've all read about it
and we've you know you've seen it in
different projects reading about it in
history books and all that stuff but
being a part of it now like us going
from city to city state to state through
different weather conditions you know
montana in the winter
texas in the summer
the layers of clothes that we have on
the you know in the summer it's just
it's tough
it's challenging and
it's only a fraction of as challenging
as it was to them back then it's a harsh
life
it's you know great western man vs man
man verse himself man vs nature and it
seems like nature is trying to kill you
at every turn every curve and the
weather conditions tornadoes uh ice
storms uh heat you know a root canal
back then could kill you like modern
medicine wasn't around
and
yeah rattlesnakes it's just it was every
turn it was it was brutal
uh one of the things about this series
is that this is not a soundstage show
this is on location and the challenges
that film that go with filming on
location
is this one of the more challenging
projects you've been a part of this is
the hardest job i've ever had doing
anything it's it's there's a reason why
they don't try and do these type of
shows very often it's beautiful when it
when you stick the landing and you see
the finished product but making it is
close to impossible like it's it's it's
an uphill battle and like
most shows 90 of shows on television
they're in a studio
and they might have a few days on
location you know for each episode
we're sun up to sundown
you know in whatever weather climate it
is whatever city whatever state you're
outside all the time in this and it's
just it's brutal and like not just
working
you're working with horses that sense
bad weather coming
and
they don't like it and if you're got a
gun if you got a shootout if you're
running around if you're supposed to be
doing a lot on the horses and they're
having a bad day that makes it
challenging you know the uh the the
temperature the cows if they don't feel
like being hurted if they just want to
break out
all right rattle you know round them
back up back to one and resets on this
show
with 25 wagons
is not like you could just back a car up
you have to do a huge loop with 25
and it's just everything takes so long
to do but it's beautiful
when it all comes together
yeah when i was watching it all i could
think about was oh my god this had to be
have been such a tough shoot you know
it's like movie level in terms of how
much is going on yeah we had uh six
sometimes eight cameras we had drones we
had helicopters like to try to capture
everything it's such a
you know this huge you know production
there's 400 people you know cast and
crew
it's it was
it was an undertaking but as hard as it
is to film
is as beautiful as it looks when you
stick the landing and you see it on the
screen it just it brings you to the
place where we we want you to come to
what do what did you what do you most
respond to taylor's writing obviously
he's a very talented screenwriter and
you know writer
uh but what are you really excited about
i'm butchering this question but i guess
what are you really excited for people
to see in the series and experience with
taylor's writing just how beautiful it
is it was poetry like everything every
time
elsa
isabelle's character narrates and she
has the voiceover
it just it you hear different things
each time
and it's just it's beautiful the the
interactions the subtle interactions
between these characters
that some other writers or some other
shows might try to hit you over the head
with it
there's subtleties in the writing that
that's so impactful and that that
resonate
and that it might be something that
resonates with me that doesn't resonate
with the rest of the people watching and
then there's another scene that they
have their moment for whatever reason
whatever your background or how you came
up that doesn't resonate with me but
there's something for everyone
in this storytelling and taylor does
that like like nobody
on that note i gotta stop i'm just gonna
say congrats pretty confident it's gonna
be ahead thank you i appreciate that